in this video we'll see how to compute
the pairwise lock factor parameter
gradients so we've seen before how to
what last function we would use for
training conditional random field and we
also partly saw how to compute the
parameter gradients of the last function
we've seen how to compute parameter
gradients for dollar involved in the log
factors the unary log factors and I will
see for the pairwise log factors so with
a derivation similar to what we've seen
in the previous video we can show that
the partial derivative of the negative
log problem
with respect to the pairwise factor
position K for observing Y the value of
the label y prime K followed by a value
of the label y prime K plus 1 is
actually equal to minus whether the KF
label in sequence Y is equal to Y prime
K and the k plus 1 yet label is equal to
BI prime K plus 1 minus the probability
according to the model that the Kiat
label would be Y prime K and the k plus
1 year label would be Y prime K plus 1
so we see it actually has a form which
is quite similar to the previous
gradient for the unary log factor
partial derivatives again it's what is
observed in the data - what the model
thinks and also the now the partial
derivatives with respect to the
parameters of the pairwise log factor is
quite simple because we're modeling
directly the pairwise log the pairwise
log factors with the matrix V then so in
other words the remove the ink here but
the pairwise factor value for y prime K
Y K Y prime K plus 1 is simply the
element that's row y prime k and column
Y prime K plus 1 in the matrix V well
because of that the partial derivatives
for that entry in the matrix
is the similar term that we saw here but
now we have to sum it over all position
K because this matrix is used for all
positions k for essentially for all the
pairwise log factor across the sequence
and now we can write it also in vector
form so get the gradient by so the
gradient of the loss with respect to the
full matrix P and we can show that it
corresponds to this sum of - the one on
vector with a 1 at position Y K times
the transpose at the one effector with a
1 at position YK plus 1 - the matrix
that contains all the pairwise marginal
probabilities that is all the
probabilities of decay at label being YK
and they keep plus 1 yes label being YK
plus 1 so this essentially this matrix
would contain all of these probabilities
here for a position k and k plus 1 and
another way of writing this is to
perform the sum here over these terms so
this root the sum here so I have the sum
over the pairwise matrix and then I can
just write this here as just a frequency
of observing a given label followed by
another given label so I'm writing it
I'm noting this down as frequents frac
YK YK plus 1 you know I could have
written just you know Y and say Y prime
the K is not important it's just the
number of times that a given label of Y
was followed by another label Y prime in
the sequence and I have the full matrix
that contains all of these pairwise
label frequencies so that's just another
way of writing down the expression for
the gradient which respectively so
that's pretty much all for the parameter
gradients a quick word on regularization
we can use the same regularizer as we
use in the non sequential neural network
and
normally we have a regular izing term
for the connection matrices the matrix
fee but we still don't recognize the
biases in the neural network we could
decide to scale the amount of
regularization by the sequence size so
if we thought that large sequences don't
necessarily have more information about
the right parameter should be them
shorter sequences then that would allow
us for instance to penalize so
regularize more on longer sequences and
less on smaller sequences so you know
that's a variant that you might see in
the literature that people might try to
adapt for some given problem but
otherwise the regularization gradients
are are essentially the same as we've
seen before and so now with the loss and
the regularization gradients and the
parameter gradients we have all the
greens we need to apply a stochastic
gradient descent and I haven't mentioned
the initialization but we use exactly
the same as we've used in the non
sequential neural networks and also
perhaps I should say that for
initialization for the matrix V it's
fine to initialize it to zero so that
pretty much gives us all the pieces we
need to apply stochastic gradient
descent training for conditional random
fields and that's it